hi I'm Chris buck and I'm F VOR and
we're here to break down the scene from
the song This
wish so this wish is it's one of those
songs that when you hear it you know
it's so powerful and so pivotal to the
movie that it became it became an anchor
to the movie it became a TCH Stone
Julian Michaels and Benjamin rice they
wrote write this beautiful song it's one
of those amazing songs that uh you're so
lucky to get if you get one in a film uh
you're extremely lucky we're lucky we
got a a whole bunch in our movie but
this wish is uh extremely special I
originally became involved with wish
because of Mr Tom mcdal um he called me
in the pandemic uh at in in 2020 and was
like we're working on a new movie uh I
can't tell you what yet but would you
want to try for the film basically and I
was like yes please yes it started as an
idea and then uh and then I called this
wonderful man and I was like hey want to
do a Disney movie with me I said I think
about it about six months later no I
said yes uh yeah that's how it kind of
happened tell in the story of wish in
this film we talk a lot about the
recognition of someone's power within to
make the dream come true themselves and
the first step is to recognize what your
wish is and find a courage to speak
about it and when Julia wrote this song
A lot of it was
about a negotiating with yourself
finding out what to do and eventually
with that bridge that has a lot of
contemporary sound I love so much within
that she found the courage to finally
talk about what she wanted out loud into
the universe if you will which then
launch her into this entire Journey this
was started as sort of an idea uh it was
about a young
courageous uh girl that does a very
selfless thing and I think when you
think I want songs those are
particularly for yourself and she just
seemed way too self to want a song for
herself and uh and so I think we just
sort of took that approach when it came
to writing the lyrics for this song and
um we knew we wanted it to feel really
classic because obviously we're making a
trying to make a Timeless Disney song
but also wanted it to feel really modern
what Julia did was really Embrace kind
of the Disney classic sound but also
bring her own contemporary sound to it
and and that's what we were thrilled
about we were thrilled that she was
bringing herself to the movie it's
everything we wanted to do with this
movie and that is embrace our Legacy but
also sort of embrace the sound of today
the look of today so I had the pleasure
of storyboarding this sequence and as in
all the songs I have boarded before you
start with listening to it a lot of
times and trying to embody the feelings
of what the
characters uh going through and for this
wish Chris and I sat down and we break
down each of the verse of the meaning of
it there's a story of a girl who has to
negotiate this is the entire world I
used to know I walk through the street
every day I know every single person I
talk to them every day know their names
and now that when I see them I know more
about them now from being with
magnifical earlier and get to see you
know a person's wildest biggest dreams
and feeling
sad and frustrated that these dream may
never come true and she didn't know what
to do right and we we bring in the
symbolism of birds in the town square
that is the only like they are the only
animals that can reach up to the sky
while Asha not knowing that's what she
needed to do but as the birds flew up
into the sky the people of roses look up
to that there still glimmer of hope and
the glimmer of hope is is up there hi
waiting for her to recognize that and
the second verse of the song is all
about magnifical because it's it's not
enough just to know what you you know
what you want we want to talk also about
what she's up against and magnifical is
a big obstacle so there's a lot of
imagery of magnifical everywhere from
reflection on the water up on the wall
there's this um towering ble that we're
asking the audience do you think Asha is
going to find the courage to go against
this very powerful person and the idea
of her
father and her Wishing on that tree we
reference the tree later in the movie
when Ash is thinking about what to do
should she should she turn back and and
help ress and she sees the tree as the
story evolved Julia brought that
beautiful moment in to the song of
remembering her father father
remembering their time when they did
they did wish together um and it's so
powerful in the song now every single
time it feels completely surreal I still
get a little teary eyed when she looks
up at the tree she's going to say up at
the
tree every time she looks up the tree at
her dad still still gets me we are so
lucky to have Ariana debose Ariana is
just um just a super Talent you know
when she hit the the recording Studio it
was just you know one fantastic take
after another and it really set up the
anchor of the story right this wish
comes and it inspired at all costs it
inspired welcome to rosess it kind of
radiates out from this
[Music]
moment so I make this
wish to have something more for us than
this
so I make this wish to have something
more for us
[Music]
this
more so I make this wish
to have something more for us than
[Music]
this